but andrew yang mentioned something on
the
that it cost uh 400 000
over 400 thousand dollars per year to
support
one person in prison in new york
like when i heard that number it was
really confusing to me
like that it cost that much 400k per
person
uh and it was really refreshing to hear
a politician
describe a particular problem with data
that this is
this prison industrial complex whatever
the hell it is
and whether the solution it's unclear
what the solution is
i think he has solutions but just the
honesty of presenting that information
was refreshing and i'm not sure a
capitalistic person would solve that
those kinds of problems he might make
worse and i'm not you know
i'm a huge fan of capitalism i think
i think the free market is is the way we
make progress in this world but
it seems to go wrong in certain
directions
like the military-industrial complex the
prison anything that
ends with industrial complex and so i'm
i'm not sure i'm not sure if all of the
problems
you're basically saying
let's put new york's problems aside
we need to have new york shine first to
do what it does
best essentially yeah and then the
problems will fix them
well and then we can focus on the
problems but if you just say like here's
a problem here's the problem here's a
problem
let's make sure we have the safety net
that protects against all these kinds of
problems that's not going to
that's going to kill the city the spirit
of the uh of the city
that is in your biased opinion the rome
of the world
that said a lot of people are fleeing
new york yeah that's why i say it
that's the reality of the situation is
you know um
i i'm all for the public good but yeah
there needs to be back to that greek
expression pan metro narration i
i also think the free market is
responsible for progress
i think it's the most natural thing the
thing that's most aligned with human
nature which is self-interest
and um which i believe not to the extent
that iran would but i do believe people
are mostly self-interested
especially with one gun to the head um
morals are out the window
you know it's about survival so you know
create a system
that respects that and acknowledges that
but socialism works very well at least
right now
as a check as to temper uh the excesses
of capitalism and in certain scenarios
is uh the more appropriate system you
know in a vacuum so one being
prisons or you know uh you know uh
governance uh you know uh maybe even
well
and this is a difficult one but in
healthcare healthcare it's unclear
what's
right there's a lot of debates there
yeah doctors want boats
so i guess you're voting for aoc you're
saying no i'm not getting vote for issue
but i do
it's just a tough one that's a tough one
but ultimately
the hippocratic oath it's like how do
you turn people away man how do you do
that to people it's like
it's it's a tough thing to uh
to reconcile helping people curing
people with
the uh the marketplace it's just i can
understand why that one's so tough
and then you got hypochondriacs of
course who drain the system you know
like people who are
have anxiety like me who had coveted
called 14
uh you know i called 14 ambulances
you